[Música]
porque con nuestro segundo invitado del
día vamos a hablar del north swing 1 y
el suministro de gas a europa los
posibles escenarios que hay sobre la
mesa luego de lo que ocurrió el temor de
la unión europea por un corte total del
suministro
recordemos que estuvo parado diez días
este suministro de gas desde rusia a la
unión europea por mantenimiento una
turbina que tenía que llegar de canadá
que finalmente no se llevaba a rusia por
estas sanciones impuestas por occidente
a rusia por la guerra en ucrania
precisamente finalmente hoy entonces ya
se reanudó ese suministro pero con un 30
por ciento del total de su capacidad
todavía digamos que sigue el temor de
los europeos que también dicen que rusia
en muchas formas utiliza entonces la
energía y los alimentos- también pero
eso ya otros temas como arma de guerra
está aquí por supuesto daniela hablando
no con nosotros en nuestra mesa de
trabajo a ni para hablar de este tema
que por supuesto afecta también la
economía no da ni bienvenida muy buen
día muy buen día raúl claro que sí
además que el gas se utiliza en una
serie de procesos que ni siquiera
nosotros alcanzamos a ver desde de
hierro para fabricar carros hasta
fabricar botellas de vidrio también para
pasteurizar leche que es una salida de
proceso ni siquiera la gente sabe que
para eso sentimos que afectaría digamos
también la alimentación industrial la
alimentación de toda una población en
este caso principalmente el europea
saludamos a daniel montamat abogado
economista del secretario energía
nacional ex director de gas del estado
en argentina estamos daniela con él que
es daniel de muy buen día gracias por
estar con nosotros en directo américa de
france 24
si los días buenos días
hola
daniel bueno la primera pregunta sin
duda alguna es qué pasaría si este
gasoducto no hubiera entra en
funcionamiento hoy de hecho entró en
funcionamiento pero con más poca
capacidad
a ver para entender la importancia
estratégica del nord stream 1 tengamos
en cuenta sobre datos del año pasado que
europa la unión europea importa
alrededor de
450 millones de metros cúbicos día de
gas de rusia y el norte string 1
esos volúmenes totales alrededor de un
tercio
150 millones de metros cúbicos diga así
que tiene una importancia estratégica
dentro del suministro de rusia a la
unión europea
obviamente qué
en la situación actual donde rusia ya ha
cortado algunos suministros por ejemplo
polonia por ejemplo a bulgaria dinamarca
pero seguía
transportando la mayor parte de los
volúmenes a través de estos casos es
bueno una de las dudas que abrió el tema
de la parada técnica en este gasoducto
es que van a restablecer estos volúmenes
porque estamos hablando de volúmenes de
150 millones de metros cúbicos días
y se ha restablecido en parte en sus
jueces y por eso la unión europea está
buscando es reducir
la dependencia de ese consumo ruso
pensando en que la situación se puede
agravar el hecho de que no se
restablezcan totalmente los flujos por
este gasoducto
impide algunos países de la unión
europea seguir almacenando gas para la
instancia que se viene en el próximo
invierno con lo cual es importante que
haya medidas concertadas en la unión
europea para lo que se plantea ahora
como la necesidad y ahorrar gas he hecho
un planteo de ahorrar unos 100 millones
de metros cúbicos/día
modificando termostatos etcétera
etcétera aprovechando todavía de la
estación
calor y previendo de que eso va a
permitir
ahorrar cierto flujo para almacenar gas
para la instancia invierno daniel le
pregunto si este ahorro realmente es es
suficiente además también lo
conversábamos con daniela blandón y nos
estaba contando que pues que este ahorro
debería ser más evidentemente de las
personas pero también de las empresas
que son las que más gas consumen sería
suficiente este ahorro para poder durar
hasta el invierno y digamos viendo todo
el panorama cómo está de a lo mejor un
posible corte del suministro completo
europa hacia donde debe mirar para tener
este recurso
empecemos por donde está mirando se ha
tratado de aumentar el súbdito de
azerbaiyán se ha tratado de aumentar el
suministro que viene de la huelga el mar
del norte de eeuu está exportando das
por bar con doble de lo que exportaba el
año pasado y se está buscando el mayor
suministro de argelia y otras fuentes
africanas pero usted lo observa bien no
es tan fácil sustituir gas que viene por
instalaciones que viene operando desde
hace tiempo
por instalaciones que hoy están
saturadas o que requieren nueva
infraestructura así que yo creo que si
el esfuerzo tiene que ser concertado de
familias y empresas ahí hay una hoja de
ruta que ha planteado la presidenta de
la unión europea a los efectos de llevar
adelante este ahorro de cualquier manera
3 creo que por las circunstancias
especiales del conflicto bélico
no va a ser fácil llegar con los ahorros
a la instancia de poder de tener
suficiente gas
invierno con el cual se está pelando a
otra fuente alemania se están poniendo
minas y carbón
cita
digamos
rompiendo un poco los compromisos de la
agenda ambiental el señor daniel el
problema no solamente es que estas
instalaciones ya estén llenas o de la
dificultad que tengan para llevarlos
sino también los precios porque no es lo
mismo un gas que les llega a uno por un
gasoducto que un gas que le llega por
una planta de regasificación por el mar
entonces para que deben prepararse
también los europeos que ya están viendo
precios muy altos en comparación con el
año pasado o antes de la guerra para que
deben prepararse entonces para no
solamente para enfrentar racionamiento
sino tener aumentos de hasta cuánto
mire días pasados la argentina tuvo que
rechazar la compra de tres barcos de gl
porque las cotizaciones se daba 50
dólares en emisión de vtv te doy una
idea de los pesos promedio del año
pasado que pagó la argentina por la
importación de gn el polo de 833 dólares
así que sí creo que europa debe
prepararse para lo que aquí en lenguaje
latinoamericano llamamos una frazada
corta
trazada corta es que va a haber menos
oferta que va a haber que tratar de
ahorrar la ministro pero que hay que
prepararse para precios más caros